Quiero contarles una historia
que conecta el célebre incidente de privacidad
que involucró a Adán y Eva,
y el cambio notorio de los límites
entre lo público y lo privado
ocurrido en los últimos 10 años.
Ya conocen el incidente.
Adán y Eva, un día en el Jardín del Edén,
se dan cuenta de que están desnudos.
Se asustan.
Y el resto es historia.
Hoy en día, Adán y Eva
probablemente actuarían diferente.
[@Adan ¡Lo de anoche fue genial! Me encantó la manzana LOL] (Risas)
(Risas) [@Eva Sip... bebé, ¿sabes qué le pasó a mis pantalones?]
Revelamos mucha más información
personal en línea que nunca antes,
y las empresas recolectan mucha más
información sobre nosotros.
Podemos ganar mucho y beneficiarnos
del análisis masivo de esta información personal,
o "big data",
pero también hay un precio grande que pagar en términos de privacidad,
[Salí por una pizza] [Mis amigos y la NSA]
en contraprestación.
Mi historia trata de esas contraprestaciones.
Empecemos con un verdad que, en mi opinión,
se ha hecho cada vez más evidente en los últimos años:
toda información personal
puede volverse sensible.
En el 2000, se tomaron unos 100 000 millones
de fotos en el mundo,
pero solo una ínfima parte de ellas
se subíeron a la Web.
En el 2010, solo en Facebook, en un solo mes,
se subieron 2500 millones de fotos,
la mayoría identificadas.
En el mismo lapso de tiempo,
la capacidad de las computadoras para reconocer personas en las fotos
mejoró en tres órdenes de magnitud.
¿Qué ocurre cuando uno combina
estas tecnologías:
aumento de la disponibilidad de datos faciales;
mejora en el reconocimiento facial informático;
y también la computación en la nube,
que nos da a todos los presentes en la sala
el poder computacional
que hace unos años estaba disponible
solo para agencias gubernamentales;
y la computación ubicua,
que le permite a mi móvil, que no es una supercomputadora,
conectarse a Internet
y tomar allí cientos de miles
de medidas faciales en unos pocos segundos?
Bueno, pensamos que el resultado
de esta combinación de tecnologías
será un cambio radical en nuestras nociones
de privacidad y anonimato.
Para comprobalo hicimos un experimento
en el campus del Carnegie Mellon.
Le pedimos a los estudiantes que pasaban por allí
que participaran en un estudio,
les tomamos una foto con una cámara web
y les pedimos que completaran una encuesta en el portátil.
Mientras completaban la encuesta,
subimos la foto a un clúster de computación en la nube,
y usamos un reconocedor facial
para cotejar esa foto con una base de datos
de cientos de miles de imágenes
que habíamos bajado de perfiles de Facebook.
Para cuando el sujeto llegaba al final
de la encuesta, la página se había actualizado en forma dinámica
con las 10 fotos encontradas por el reconocedor
que mejor concordaban,
y le pedímos al sujeto que indicara
si se encontraba en la foto.
¿Ven al sujeto?
Bueno, la computadora sí, y de hecho,
reconoció 1 de cada 3 sujetos.
En esencia, podemos partir de un rostro anónimo,
en disco o en la web, y usar el reconocimiento facial
para ponerle nombre a ese rostro anónimo
gracias a las redes sociales.
Pero hace unos años hicimos algo más.
Partimos de datos de redes sociales,
los combinamos estadísticamente con datos
de la seguridad social del gobierno de EE.UU.
y terminamos prediciendo los números de la seguridad social,
que en Estados Unidos
son una información extremadamente sensible.
¿Ven a dónde quiero llegar con esto?
Si combinan los dos estudios,
entonces la pregunta pasa a ser:
¿Podemos partir de un rostro
y mediante reconocimiento facial, hallar un nombre
e información pública
sobre ese nombre y esa persona,
y a partir de esa información pública
inferir información no pública,
mucho más sensible,
para luego asociarla a aquel rostro?
La respuesta es sí se puede, y lo hicimos.
Por supuesto, la precisión va desmejorando a cada paso.
[Se identificó el 27% de los 5 primeros dígitos del SSN de los sujetos (con 4 intentos)]
Decidimos incluso, desarrollar una app para iPhone,
que usa la cámara interna del móvil
para tomar una foto del sujeto
y subirla a la nube,
y luego hacer lo que les describí en tiempo real:
cotejarla, encontrar información pública,
tratar de inferir información sensible,
y luego enviarla nuevamente al móvil
para ser superpuesta en el rostro del sujeto,
un ejemplo de realidad aumentada,
quizá un ejemplo escalofriante de realidad aumentada.
De hecho, no desarrollamos la app para que estuviera disponible,
sino como una prueba de concepto.
Incluso tomamos estas tecnologías
y las llevamos al extremo lógico.
Imaginen un futuro en el que los extraños que los rodeen
los miren con sus gafas Google
o, algún día, con sus lentes de contacto,
y usen 7 o 8 datos de ustedes
para inferir todo lo demás
que pueda saberse.
¿Cómo será ese futuro sin secretos?
¿Debería importarnos?
Nos gustaría creer
que un futuro con tanta riqueza de datos
sería un futuro sin más prejuicios,
pero, de hecho, contar con tanta información
no significa que tomaremos decisiones
más objetivas.
En otro experimento, presentamos a nuestros sujetos
información sobre un potencial candidato laboral.
incluimos algunas referencias
a cierta información totalmente legal,
divertida pero un poco embarazosa,
que el candidato había publicado en línea.
Curiosamente, entre nuestros sujetos
algunos habían publicado información similar
y otros no.
¿Qué grupo ceeen
que mostró propensión a juzgar con más severidad a nuestro sujeto?
Paradójicamente, fue el grupo
que había publicado información similar,
un ejemplo de disonancia moral.
Quizá estén pensando
que eso no los afecta a Uds.
porque no tienen nada que ocultar.
Pero, de hecho, la privacidad no tiene que ver
con tener algo negativo que ocultar.
Imaginen que son el director de RR.HH.
de cierta empresa, que reciben unas hojas de vida
y deciden buscar más información sobre los candidatos.
Entonces, googlean sus nombres
y en determinado universo
encuentran esta información--
O en un universo paralelo, encuentran esta información.
¿Creen que todos los candidatos tendrían con Uds.
la misma oportunidad de ser llamados para una entrevista?
Si piensan que sí, entonces no son
como los empleadores de EE.UU. ya que, de hecho,
en algún punto de nuestro experimento hicimos exactamente eso.
Creamos perfiles de Facebook, manipulamos los rasgos,
y luego empezamos a enviar hojas de vida a empresas en EE.UU.,
y detectamos, monitoreamos,
si estaban buscando información de nuestros candidatos,
y si actuaban con base en la información
que encontraban en los medios sociales. Y lo hicieron.
Se discriminó con base en los medios sociales
a candidatos con iguales habilidades.
Los vendedores quieren que creamos
que toda la información sobre nosotros siempre
será usada a nuestro favor.
Pero piensen de nuevo. ¿Por qué habría de ser siempre así?
En una película de hace unos años,
"Minority Report", en una escena famosa
Tom Cruise camina por un centro comercial
rodeado de publicidad
holográfica personalizada.
La película transcurre en el 2054,
dentro de unos 40 años,
y aunque la tecnología luce emocionante,
subestima en mucho
la cantidad de información que las organizaciones
pueden recolectar sobre nosotros, y la forma de usarla
para influir en nosotros de maneras imperceptibles.
Como ejemplo, está este otro experimento
que estamos haciendo y que todavía no terminamos.
Imaginemos que una organización tiene acceso
a tu lista de amigos de Facebook,
y mediante algún tipo de algoritmo
puede identificar sus dos mejores amigos.
Que luego crean, en tiempo real,
un rostro compuesto de estos dos amigos.
Estudios previos al nuestro han demostrado que las personas
no se reconocen ni a sí mismas
en rostros compuestos, pero reaccionan
a esas composiciones de manera positiva.
Y entonces, la próxima vez que busquen algún producto
y que haya una publicidad sugiriéndoles que lo compren,
no será un vendedor común.
Será uno de sus amigos,
y ni siquiera sabrán lo que está pasando.
El problema es que
los mecanismos que tenemos en la política acutal
para la protección contra los abusos de la información personal
son como llevar un cuchillo a un tiroteo.
Uno de estos mecanismos es la transparencia,
decirle a las personas lo que uno va a hacer con sus datos.
En principio, eso es algo muy bueno.
Es necesario, pero no es suficiente.
La transparencia puede estar mal dirigida.
Uno puede contarle a la gente lo que hará,
y luego empujarlos a revelar
cantidades arbitrarias de información personal.
Por eso en un experimento más, este con estudiantes,
les pedimos que nos dieran información
sobre su comportamiento en el campus,
formulándoles preguntas tan sensibles como estas.
[¿Alguna vez te copiaste en un examen?]
A un grupo de sujetos les dijimos:
"Solo otro grupo de estudiantes verá sus respuestas".
A otro grupo de sujetos les dijimos:
"Sus respuestas serán vistas por estudiantes y profesores".
Transparencia. Notificación. Y por supuesto, esto funcionó,
en el sentido de que el primer grupo de sujetos
fue mucho más propenso a revelar información que el segundo.
Tiene sentido, ¿no?
Pero luego añadimos un distractor.
Repetimos el experimento con los mismos dos grupos,
esta vez añadiendo una demora
entre el tiempo en que le dijimos a los sujetos
cómo usaríamos sus datos
y el tiempo en que empezamos a [formular] las preguntas.
¿Cuánta demora creen que tuvimos que añadir
para anular el efecto inhibidor
de saber que los profesores verían sus respuestas?
¿10 minutos?
¿5 minutos?
¿1 minuto?
¿Qué tal 15 segundos?
Quince segundos fueron suficientes para que ambos grupos
revelaran la misma cantidad de información,
como si al segundo grupo no le importara más
que los profesores leyeran sus respuestas.
Tengo que admitir que esta charla hasta ahora
puede sonar en extremo negativa,
pero esa no es mi intención.
De hecho, quiero compartir con Uds.
las alternativas que hay.
La forma en que hacemos las cosas ahora no es la única
forma de hacerlas, y ciertamente no es la mejor
forma en que pueden ser hechas.
Cuando alguien les diga: "La gente no se preocupa por la privacidad",
piensen si el juego no ha sido diseñado
y manipulado para que no se preocupen por la privacidad,
y cuando concluyamos que que estas manipulaciones ocurren,
ya estaremos a mitad de camino
de poder autoprotegernos.
Si alguien les dice que la privacidad es incompatible
con los beneficios del "big data",
piensen que en los últimos 20 años,
los investigadores han creado tecnologías
que permiten que virtualmente cualquier transacción electrónica
se realice en formas más preservadoras de la privacidad.
Podemos navegar Internet en forma anónima.
Podemos enviar correos electrónicos que solo pueda leer
el destinatario, y no la NSA [agencia de seguridad].
Podemos proteger incluso la privacidad de la minería de datos.
En otras palabras, podemos tener los beneficios del "big data"
y proteger la privacidad.
Estas tecnologías, claro está, implican una inversión
de la relacón costo- beneficio
para los tenedores de los datos,
razón por la cual, quizá, no escuchamos mucho de ellas.
Eso me lleva de vuelta al Jardín del Edén.
Hay una segunda interpretación de la privacidad
en la historia del Jardín del Edén
que no tiene que ver con el tema
del desnudo de Adán y Eva
ni con sentir vergüenza.
Pueden encontrar ecos de esta interpretación
en "El paraíso perdido" de John Milton.
En el jardín, Adán y Eva están materialmente contentos.
Están felices. Están satisfechos.
No obstante, carecen de conocimiento
y de autoconciencia.
En el momento en que comen el bien llamado
fruto del conocimiento,
es cuando se descubren a sí mismos.
Se hacen conscientes. Logran autonomía.
El precio a pagar, sin embargo, es abandonar el jardín.
La privacidad, en cierto modo, es tanto el medio
como el precio a pagar por la libertad.
Y los vendedores otra vez nos dicen
que el "big data" y los medios sociales
no son solo un paraíso de ganancias para ellos,
sino el Jardín del Edén para el resto de nosotros.
Recibimos contenido gratis.
Podemos jugar a Angry Birds. Tenemos aplicaciones específicas.
Pero, de hecho, en unos años, las organizaciones
sabrán tanto de nosotros
que podrán inferir nuestros deseos
incluso antes de formularlos y quizá hasta
compren productos en nuestro nombre
antes de que sepamos que los necesitamos.
Hay un escritor inglés
que anticipó esta especie de futuro
en el que cambiaríamos
nuestra autonomía y libertad por comodidad--
Incluso más que George Orwell.
El autor es, por supuesto, Aldous Huxley.
En "Un mundo feliz", él imagina una sociedad
en la que las tecnologías que creamos
en principio para la libertad
terminan coaccionándonos.
Sin embargo, en el libro, él también nos ofrece una salida
de esa sociedad, similar al sendero
que Adán y Eva tuvieron que seguir para salir del jardín.
En palabras de Savage,
recuperar la autonomía y la libertad es posible,
aunque el precio a pagar es elevado.
Por eso creo que una de las peleas decisivas
de nuestros tiempos será la pelea
por el control de la información personal,
la pelea porque el "big data" se vuelva una fuerza
de libertad,
en lugar de una fuerza que nos manipule desde las sombras.
Muchos de nosotros
ni siquiera sabemos que se está dando esta pelea,
pero es así, nos guste o no.
Y a riesgo de interpretar a la serpiente,
les diré que las herramientas para pelear
están aquí, la conciencia de lo que ocurre,
y en sus manos,
a unos pocos clics de distancia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)